لم يكن من المفترض أن يكون رئيسًا للوزراء
على الأقل ليس بعد ،
ولكن في عام 2021 فتح حزبه الصغير
الباب أمام حكومة جديدة أنهت
فترة رئاسة بنيامين نتنياهو
كرئيس وزراء إسرائيلي لأطول مدة خدمة ،
وبهذا أصبح المليونير صاحب التكنولوجيا العالية
هو صاحب الدولة.  رئيس الوزراء الثالث عشر
نفتالي بينيت ، زعيم حزب اليمين اليميني يمينا
ينضم
إلى زملائه غير المتوقعين لتشكيل التحالف الأكثر
تنوعًا في تاريخ إسرائيل
بينيت زعيم المستوطنين السابق المتدين الذي يرتدي الكيباه
ويجلس إلى جانب
الأحزاب اليسارية التي سخر منها ذات مرة
وأول حزب عربي  في ائتلاف حاكم
كنا نعلم أنه سيكون
صعبًا ، علمنا أنه عندما
تجمع بين العلمانيين والدينيين يمينًا
ويسارًا ويهودًا وعربًا معًا
، ستكون هناك عقبات في الطريق ، لكن
هذا هو التحدي مع العديد من
المواقف المتعارضة تمامًا.
ووافق التحالف على تجنب إجراء تغييرات كبيرة
في قضايا مانعة الصواعق خاصة
فيما يتعلق بأي تحرك نحو محادثات السلام
مع فلسطين  الجواب
[موسيقى]
ولكن تسجيل إنجازات في أماكن أخرى
تمرير الميزانية الأولى منذ ما يقرب من أربع
سنوات
بناء تحالفات أمنية على
خلفية اتفاقيات تطبيع اتفاق
إبراهيم ، أصبح بينيت أول رئيس
وزراء إسرائيلي يزور
الإمارات العربية المتحدة والبحرين ، إنها حكومة
لها العديد من الإنجازات  بالمقارنة
مع فترة قصيرة وضيقة
نيابية وأغلبية ، فإن ما
لم تنجح في فعله هو إنقاذ
إسرائيل أو انتزاعها
من
حرب الهوية الثقافية الداخلية ، وفي هذا الصدد كانت هذه
الحكومة أقرب إلى وقف إطلاق النار
بدلاً من
إنهاء الحرب.  الجمود
السياسي وفي النهاية كان أعضاء
حزب بينيت هم من أسقطه في النهاية من
خلال الانشقاق تاركين فرصة
للمعارضة التي يقودها نتنياهو
لحل البرلمان
، التجربة الكبرى التي بالكاد عمرها عام واحد والتي أدت إلى
إرسال الإسرائيليين مرة أخرى
إلى صناديق الاقتراع.  للمرة الخامسة في ما
يزيد قليلا عن ثلاث سنوات قدس الذهب cnn
القدس